you got to go to Gainesville now I do
Gainesville Florida is where the Florida
florid show me mad love though like I
have a good fan base in Florida though
where where in Florida have you
performed um
Orlando uh
Miami Miami's nice somewhere else have
you been in the strip clubs in Miami yet
booby trap booby trap's a movie it's
also un it's almost
booby trap is a real thing when you're
in booby trap you're really trapped and
you can't leave and I don't like to
party but you don't want to leave the
Ubers are taking forever to get there
there's a line outside it's [__] 700
in the morning I'm tired I'm miserable
Miser you be what I I mean after pulling
an all nighter and I'm on [__] jet
lag from the West Coast n no no and then
you're with this guy DJ AO he's a
psychopath good guy though I'm sure
you've met him he's I had a time in my
life at booby trap I couldn't believe I
a want to leave my team kept saying you
ready to go you spend a lot of money you
oh no I didn't no I no I don't do those
type things did you eat did I they got
they got food at booby trap I'm I don't
remember they got some of the best strip
club food in the country is in Florida
Miami specifically G5 has great wings um
uncle trick uh made sure he fed me when
I came out there his food was really
Trick Daddy fed you what did he cook cuz
you know he cook I mean he got he got a
he got a spot I didn't know that yeah he
got a restaurant was it good it's called
Uh Sunday's what um Sunday eer Sunday I
think he was on Cribs or some show
cooking some wild [__] you remember that
yeah he
shout Tri Florida like pancake thing he
was cooking no I had some turkey wings
turkey wings did I was it yeah I had
some turkey wings uh are those bigger
than chicken wings it was fire I've had
a turkey leg I've never had a turkey
wing at like a restaurant turkey no I
mean that's why you got that restaurant
because I got to go I've only been to
like uh finger licking which and my
household turkey wings was a thing but
not for me I didn't like turkey wings
until I got older you got to go to
tootsies and get the fried lobster tail
while a lady massages you they have uh
they have non strippers there what type
of freaky eery is that no no no it's
tootsies tootsies is a legendary strip
club you know Drake said I'm toots
shoulder rubs I've never I've never been
there so tootsies they have dancers and
then they have literal fully clothed
lady like Mass's so like some someone's
Auntie is in there like they'll rub your
back for like 45 minutes for or 45 bucks
I think is for 30 minutes or something
like that or it's 45 bucks for 15
minutes and it's amazing so you're just
sitting there eating maybe the fight's
on maybe the Dolphins are playing and
then you got a lady giving you a real
massage like a real massage it's not
like no weirdo [__] like it's a real
masseuse oh really survive yeah oh I got
to go it's it's not a bad place I got to
go but booby trap's a movie for sure
yeah booby trap is a trap for sure you
know what I noticed when you go to the
Shri Club in New York it's more about
the bartenders than it is the
dancers is that fair oh that's a New
York thing yeah that's a New York thing
right yeah like bartenders might get
more love than strippers for sure yeah
mhm